Just before we get started,
some of you might know that I have another channel called mega projects,
which is all about mega-projects. If you don't please do subscribe to us well,
by popular demand,
I wanted to cover some things on that channel that weren't quite mega enough for
it. So I present to you a brand new channel side projects,
covering secret Soviet space, weapons, world war two's, greatest airplanes,
histories, lost treasures, and a whole lot more new videos,
three times a week on that channel.
So if you're thinking Simon doesn't make enough videos for me, well,
problem-solved link below and let's get into it
Today. We take a look at a pirates I'm like any other Steed bonus,
the gentleman pirates so-called because he came from a life of luxury and
leisure. He was wealthy. He was well-educated.
He was influential in high society.
And yet he left that life behind and instead decided to become a pirate,
his motivation,
whatever it was already makes him unique among the pirates we've covered on this
channel.
But another original aspects of botanists was that he was completely ill
prepared for life. As a pirate captain, he didn't know how to sail.
He didn't know how to navigate, and he didn't know how to fight,
but that did not deter him in the slightest.
Although it did cause some slight friction with his men,
this almost makes him a sort of comical character,
especially when compared to his peers, but to everyone's surprise,
he wasn't the most terrible pirate in the world.
He took his fair share of prizes and secured long lasting notoriety for himself.
Thanks mainly to his association with black debt. In the end, though,
Steve bonnet proved to be a tragic figure as the rest of the world wasn't as
impressed or amused by his antics. And ultimately he shared the same harsh face.
As most of us Confederate.
Steve Barnett was born in 1688 on the islands of Barbados.
He came from a wealthy family. His parents had a large plantation,
a couple of miles from the Barbadian Capitol of Bridgetown and he inherited it
all. Once his parents died,
he received a good education and was brought up to be a proper and upstanding
member of society. As a young adult bonnet,
married a woman named Mary Allenby in 1709 and together they had four children
through the years. He saw his standing in society, steadily improve.
His wife was also the daughter of a wealthy planter.
So he got a large dowery by marrying her and his own plantation seemed to
thrive.
He joined the British army and services and the local militia where he attained
the rank of major. In other words, Steve bonnets seemingly had everything.
That's a man of the era could have a once.
And yet he did something strange in 17, 17,
something that puzzled his contemporaries and still puzzles historians to this
day, he gave up his life and decided he wants to become a pirate.
What exactly prompted phonics to do this remains a mystery.
The main motives why men turned to piracy in those days was because they didn't
know how to make money any other way,
or because they wanted to escape the oppression of their governments because
they were forced into it. None of the above applying to Steve bonus,
he was considered a gentleman of leisure as well. If you had the money,
the influence and the status to live out, all his, he is uncomfort.
But for some reason, this did not appeal to him. Instead,
he preferred to risk his life on the high seas. So why did he do it?
Both his contemporaries and modern historians have offered their opinions.
Some simply believe that he was bored and wanted a bit of excitement in his
life. If this is true,
then Steve Barnett should definitely be in contention for the most extreme
midlife crisis. In history.
Others thought that he suffered from some kind of mental illness. Well,
Charles Johnson in his seminar accounts,
a general history of pirates claimed that bonnet wanted to leave his old life
behind due to some discomfort.
He found in a married state implying that Steve bonnets was doing all of this
just to get away from his wife.
There is also a possibility that his financial situation may not have been as
comfortable as we previously suggested.
As there is a record of him borrowing 1,700 pounds at the start of the year,
maybe a poor harvesting season left him in dire straits and bonnets thought he
had no alternative, but to turn to piracy,
or maybe he'd already made up his mind and knew that it never have to pay the
loan back.
Ultimately all of these hypotheses remain guesswork since Bonner's himself never
gave an explicit reason. Speaking of Charles Johnson,
we often start off these pirate buyers specifying that he is the main source.
And also that is not particularly reliable.
So everything has to be taken with a grain of salt. Well,
that is not necessarily true in this case because although a general history of
pirates remains an important source,
we actually have a more trustworthy secondary one because Steve Bonnett was
arrested and tried for piracy.
A detailed accounts of his trial in South Carolina was published and survives to
this day. So we have corroboration of the things he did as a pilot.
We said in 17, 17, Steve Barnett left his life behind to became a pirate.
Like every other pirate captain bonnet did not steal his ship. He purchased it.
It was a sleep which he named the revenge and had it fitted with 10 cannons.
He also hired his crew around 70 to 80 men who received a monthly salary,
paid out of bonnets own pocket,
instead of simply awarding them a share of the plunder.
This was probably done more out of necessity.
Seeing as alibi recru could depose their captain for being in competence and
then vote on somebody else to take his place.
This was probably the only way that bonnet could have maintained his captaincy,
given that he knew almost nothing.
When it came to sailing navigation or maritime warfare,
once Bonnie has had his ship ready and his crew assembled,
he needed to wait for the right opportunity.
The revenge stayed quietly in the Harbor for a few days.
And everyone who inquired was simply told the bonnet,
purchased it to stop trading with the nearby islands.
Then one night without word to his family or friends that captain abandoned his
life of leisure and set sail on the high seas,
headed for the Eastern coast of North America.
You might think this haphazard approach to would be a recipe for disaster,
but Steve Bonnett was surprisingly successful.
He took his first prizes off the coast of the colony of Virginia,
where he plans it, not one, not two but four ships in a short amount of time,
the AAN, the Tibet, the young and the endeavor.
Two of them sailed out of Scotland's and one out of England.
And those were free to go after being planted.
The turbot however was set to sell from Barbados and Bon is insisted on having
it confiscated and burned down.
He would go on to repeat this with other ships from his native islands.
We're not sure if he did this to try and prevent the word of his actions from
reaching back home, or if the harbored some kind of resentment for Barbados.
Anyway, after Virginia bonnet headed for New York,
he captured another sleep and then resupplied his ship.
According to his trial documents by August 17, 17,
the revenge was already heading back South to the coast of South Carolina.
When he captured two more ships first was a Snoop from Barbados, carrying sugar,
Robinson slaves, and captain by a man named Joseph Palmer.
And the second was a bringing team from new England down to captain Thomas
Porter. Again, bonnet burned down the ship from Barbados.
This initial run proved to be quite successful. Although realistically,
this was more due to the skill and expertise of the crew rather than bonnet
himself. By this point,
most of the pirates probably figured out that the captain was a complete rookie.
When it came to all seafaring matters in some discontented already started
brewing.
It was decided that they would make lands for awhile and go somewhere where they
could actually spend some of that ill gotten gains their vendors, self,
and the sound with The Bahamas, which was a pirate tape.
And at that time that Steve bonnet made the acquaintance of numerous other
Seadogs such as himself and among them was captain Edward teach better known as
the infamous black bit.
[Inaudible].
Off the bat.
We should mention that from this point on the career's a black bed and bonnet
into twine for a little while, we've already done a video on black bit.
So if you'd like to get more of the story from that perspective,
why not give a little looksy to that video? Anyway,
Baghdad was a skilled and experienced captain,
not to mention that he was respected and feared by screaming.
He was the antithesis of Steed bonnet,
and yet somehow the two struck up a relationship and decided to sail together
for a while.
Many would say that Blackbeard was simply using bonnet to strengthen his own
fleet. And they would probably be right.
This was before Edward teach had gotten his hands on the queen Anne's revenge as
they in flagship for most of his political career.
Having bonnets revenge on his side would have been a significant advantage.
This all worked out well for the captain from Barbados though,
at least at first is having someone like black beds in charge,
probably quelled any desire to leave or revolt that might've been developing
among bonnets group.
So the fleet left in the sour with Steve Bonner's officially a guest aboard
Blackbeard's ship.
While a Lieutenant Richards had been given temporary command of the revenge.
They proved to be a formidable force in the water surrounding The Bahamas and
took at least a dozen prizes on their way to the East coast of America. Again,
going by court records, by the time they reached North Carolina,
they had four ships in their, in between 300 to 400 fighting men.
You always think this would be a good thing for Steve bonnet as he sat out to be
a pirate captain,
not actually knowing anything about what that entails and was now part of one of
the most powerful and feared convoys in American waters. However,
that was not the case. In fact,
Bonnie was quite depressed as he realized what he truly was a prisoner who
willingly gave up command of his ship to his own camp set. Sure. On the surface,
his relationship with teach was still cordial and he wasn't deprived of his
share of the plumber.
But bonnet understood that this would only continue as long as he played the
role of the content guest,
any attempt to reclaim his authority over the revenge would have likely put an
end to all niceties and worst of all bond.
It would have probably discovered that most of his men prefer to sail under
black bed anyway,
and private Bonnie can fester some of the men who were loyal to him that he felt
tired and shameful for his actions. And if possible,
he would have gladly left the pirate life behind and started somewhere fresh and
Spain or Portugal. Let's see,
he could not bear to face a fellow Englishman allows us.
It seems the only way he would regain commands of his ship was back there,
decided to surrender it according to certain versions of the story.
This is exactly what happened.
They say that once Blackbeard captured the Concorde, which he renamed it,
the queen Anne's revenge,
he had no more need for bonnets ship and let him go independent again.
Once this happens, bond it immediately for God.
Any plans about giving up the pirate life and assumed command of the revenge
again, however, his new-found autonomy did not last long.
His inexperience once again,
caused problems with the crew after an ill-fated attempt to plunge array,
well arms merchant names, the Protestant Caesar,
and the waters of Honduras in the spring of 17, 18. Not only did he fail,
but when it was injured in the skirmish, leaving him unfit for duty.
Soon afterwards, he ran into blank bits fleet.
Again that his own men pleaded with the other captain to assume commands of the
revenge once more, which he did. But once again,
found himself Blackbeard's guest slash prisoner, some accounts like that,
of Charles Johnson, like no mention of this brief period of independence.
So whether or not it happens is actually a matter of time.
Right?
You now have, uh, when Blackbeard's and bonnet severed their ties completely.
And that's just a few months later in may 17,
18 Blackbird used this fleet to blockade the port city of Charleston,
South Carolina, or Charleston, as we call it today. Afterwards,
the ships traveled to Topsail islands off the coast of North Carolina,
which was used as a popular resting and hiding spot for pirates that the queen
ends revenge ran a grounds and became unsalvageable as did one of the smallest
leaps in the fleet with two ships lost black bed,
decided that it might be a good idea to get a pardon from the governor of North
Carolina, a man named Charles Eden,
all pirates were free to do this in an effort to make the waters of the Atlantic
safer King. George.
The first of Britain issued a proclamation for suppressing pirates in the West
Indies, which became known as the King's paws and of 1718.
Basically there was a one-time offer available to any pirates,
no matter how heinous that criminal activities work, as long as they,
before the deadline, not only with the slate be wiped clean,
but they could also receive a commission to become a pirate Hunter and take down
their former Confederates who did not accept the King's pardon back bed and
bonnet traveled to the city of barf and obtained pardons for them and their
crews from governor Eden Blackbird and his men then left on their way.
But bonnet stayed behind for a while,
hoping to get permission to become a private town during the time that he had
been a pirate England's went to war against Spain.
So he thought that he could basically continue where he left off and be on the
right side of the law. By only targeting Spanish merchants.
Eventually Bonnett was told that he could go to the islands of Saint Thomas from
where he could obtain a private tourist commission.
When he finally returned to his ship,
bonnet discovered one last treachery from black bears.
The other pirate captain had stripped to the revenge of all supplies, loot,
and useful materials,
place them aboard the other remaining sloop and took off many scholars.
Now believe that this has been his plan all along and that's he intentionally
wrecks. The queen ends revenge to have an excuse to disband his lodge crew.
As for Steve Bonetti, might've been stranded on top Sal islands,
but at least he was in command of the revenge. Again, furthermore,
his crew hated back there now.
So it was decided once the ship was repaired and see where the, again,
they would go in pursuit of the one who had betrayed them. Once they set off,
they seem noticed a group of 20 or so men Maroons on a nearby sandbar bonnet
rescued them and discovered that they were parts of Blackbeard's crew left
behind because black bear had too many hands on deck for just one ship.
As you might imagine, they also wanted revenge against their former camps in,
and they were glad to join bonnets ranks bond.
It was still much more inexperienced in matters of warfare the black days,
but he had the biggest ship,
the bigger crew and his men were highly motivated by their desire for vengeance.
It would have been an interesting parts of pirate history,
and it's a fitting ends of that chapter.
If the two met up again and engaged in one final battle,
unfortunately this never happens. Bonner's had heard words,
the black dead it's mortars, chipping, and estery called Ocker Koch endless,
but by the time he got there,
he found it empty and never again encountered the treacherous black debt.
There's no longer an option. Bonnet wanted to return to his previous plan,
traveled to St.
Thomas and receive a letter of Mark to become a private arrogant Spain. However,
there was a problem because Blackbeard had stolen all of their supplies.
They needed water, food and liquor, but that posed another problem.
They couldn't just plunder a ship. Technically they weren't pirates anymore.
As they had accepted the King's pardon? This was a one-time deal.
And if they broke it now, there would be no turning back.
They couldn't buy anything either because blank edge,
it also made off with that treasure in the ends,
they encountered a merchant ship full of goods and forced it to trade with them.
And eight off with barrels full of pork and bread.
And instead of left behind a few casks of rice, and it's an old cable,
which was the chain holding the anchor.
They were probably hoping to get away with it on a technicality since they
committed an act of trades, not piracy,
even though it had been basically forced at gunpoint and heavily one sided,
they still didn't have any liquor though, in her pirates, they might as well.
Not about any add to breathe. This is why a couple of days later they plundered,
I mean, traded with another ship,
which provided them with two hogsheads of rum and two of molasses.
It is uncertain.
What bonus plans do give them an exchange because the other ship took advantage
of an opportunity and fled before the transaction was completed.
After this all pretenses were dropped and they became full fledged pirates
again, pardon? Be damned as a precaution though,
Bon it did change his name to captain Thomas and the name of his ship to the
role. James, hoping that maybe this might conceal his identity.
What has spent a short time as captain Thomas,
but it was his most successful time.
Clearly he was no longer the same inexperienced naive man that he was when he
started. It was more respect, it's even a fit.
Some historians claim that Steve bonus was one of the few real pirates to
actually make prisoners walk. The plank is this was a practice,
mostly popularized by the book treasure islands by Robert Louis Stevenson bonnet
proud the waters of the Carolinas.
Traveling up North into Virginia and Delaware capturing almost a dozen ships of
which two. He kept sins added to his fleet.
Offer a few.
Profitable months. See Bonnie needed a place to make lands.
And Corinne has ship for repairs.
He chose the estery of Cape fear river in North Carolina hurricane season was
approaching. So this was intended to be quite a long state.
Unfortunately for bonus these last few successful months,
it also increased his profile significantly. Charles Eden,
the governor of North Carolina,
might've been somewhat indifferent to pirate activity,
but as neighboring counterparts, not as amenable,
the governance of the colonies knew that they had dangerous pirates in their
waters and wanted them dealt with consequently, the governor of South Carolina,
Robert Johnson ordered a man named Colonel William Rhett to arm to pirate
hunters and set sail to rid the colony of any pirates.
The same thing happens with the governor of Virginia who sent out his own men to
take down black bed. As far as rent is concerned.
We're not sure if he specifically targeted Steve Bonner's or if he intended to
attack any pirates.
He encountered some upsides that he simply stumbled upon bonnets fleet while
looking for Charles vane,
another infamous Piras that you'll likely see on this channel someday,
either way Rhett set out in September 17,
18 in two sleeps the Henry and the scene up and soon received word of several
pirate ships anchored at Cape fear river Colonel rats reached bonnets location.
On the night of September, the 26th, the flight commenced the next morning,
his Banos wanted to sail past the pirate hunters and had the ocean. However,
the river was not wide enough. And during the chaos, both of Rhett's ships,
as well as the roll James were grounded in shallow water.
After hours of fighting,
the South Carolina started to gain the upper hands at one point towards the ends
bonnets allegedly wanted to blow up his ship rather than be captured as,
but he was stopped by his men who decided to surrender ultimately Steed bonus
and 33 of his men survived. The battle were arrested and taken to Charlestown.
As a gentlemen,
bonnet was given preferential treatment and was allowed to in the house of the
provost Marshall on October the 24th, he actually managed to escape,
but was only at large for four days before being captured. Again,
his men didn't have a so good. After 33,
29 were found guilty of piracy and sentenced to death.
And they were all hanged on November the eighth. A few days later,
bonnets trial took place and he too was found guilty and sentenced to die.
His date of execution was scheduled for December the 10th. So,
but it still had some time to try and evade has ghastly fate. He begs,
he argued, he pleaded, he tried blaming black bear.
He wrote letters to anyone who would listen, attempt to get a sentence commuted.
He managed to get in a lot of public sympathy.
And even as capsular Colonel rat was moved to the point that he offered to
travel with Bonnie to England for a new trial.
The gentlemen pirates used as pleas and his tears to move everyone except for
the one person who mattered governor Johnson, despite public pressure,
the governor remained steadfast in his decision arguing that Bonnie had already
broken his word once.
So on December the 10th and almost insensible Steed bonus was dragged to the
gala.
Isn't in front of a crowds that exhibited more pity than contempt or hatred.
He was hanged nowadays.
A historical marker is all the remains of the spot where the notorious gentlemen
pirates and 29 of his men met their end. So I really hope you found that video.
Interesting. If you did, please do hit that thumbs up button below.
Also do subscribe.
Also check out my new channel side projects linked to below and thank you for
watching.
[Inaudible].